[موسيقى]
القصه تكمن في الاسم الذي اختاره الشفادي
قطان لمطعمه الفلسطيني الجديد في لندن
فالاسم يعود لنبته العكوب الجبليه التي
تحكي قصه تاريخ قديم بين المزارعين
الفلسطينيين ورثوها لاجيال جديده حافظت
على تقاليد مواسم قطفها واعدادها
جوهره المطبخ الفلسطيني مطبخ فلسطيني
بس الموسم مش الربيع والشتاء والخريف موسم
العكوب وموسم الباذنجان البكتيري وما موسم
الزيتون
[موسيقى]
اهل البلد
شغل تنظيف بياخذ وقت كثير
وبنطبخ او بتفرز انا برايي هايل الطاقه
اللي بتصير جميله جدا
يا زريف الطول يا شوق وحنين واشتاقت لعيون
التراب فلسطين
من المنتج الموسمي اهم ما فيه ان يكون
طازجا رغم انه لن يجد العكوب في السوق حيث
لا ينبت الا في الربيع لكن بالنسبه لفادي
فان نبته العكوب كنز تقى فيه يكشف عن
عادات المطبخ الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
من مدينته بيت لحم لينقلها معه لمطعمه
الفلسطيني الجديد في لندن
زيت الزيتون
الواقع الفلسطيني اليوم
بالارض تبعتها الناس تعيش من منتوج الارض
اليوم احنا بين ما يسمى
بين سيطره الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على المياه
وعلى الاراضي بالمايسمى مناطق ريم فعليا
ايش طالب من البريه اقل واقل واقل
انا راح اكرهك
هذا طعم البيت طعم فلسطين
طويله واختيار عكوب اسما للمطعم الفلسطيني
الجديد هنا في موطنه يهدف الى تسليط الضوء
على نبته العكوب لا في المطبخ الفلسطيني
فقط وانما في روايتي قصه تحدي يعيشها
المزارعون الفلسطيني امام محاوله تضييق
اسرائيليه على نقطه العقوب ومواسم قطرها
وهي التي باتت جزءا من تراث الثقافيه غير
مادي في الاراضي الفلسطينيه لصباح العربيه
من لندن عروب عبد الحق